getting a base hand will protect you
from a sunburn later on you know a tan
is temporary but your skin never forgets
i'm covered i applied sunscreen on my
face arms and legs
you're not covered getting sunburned
once
is harmless all it takes is one
blistering sunburn
one hi my name is jeremy brower i am a
board certified dermatologist and a
fellowship trained most surgeon i have a
new practice in westchester new york
called spectrum skin and laser as well
as practicing in manhattan for about a
decade
hi i'm dr michelle henry i'm a board
certified dermatologist and skin cancer
surgeon i have a practice called skin
and aesthetic surgery of manhattan
i specialize in higher skin cancers
lasers aesthetics and general
dermatology
and today we'll be debunking myths about
sun care
a higher spf is always better so that i
would have to say is a myth
spf is great when we think about uvb or
ultraviolet b-rays but we also have to
worry about our ultraviolet a-rays which
also cause
sun damage and skin cancer so in that
regard you're looking more for a broad
spectrum
uva uvb protective sunscreen the other
part of this that makes it a myth is
higher is not always better yes 30 is
better than 15
50 is better than 30 but at some point
roughly around 50 you're already at 98
blocking of your uvb rays and spf 100
only takes you one percent more to 99
and is that really significant likely
not what's most important to me is that
you're wearing 50 when you're outdoors
you also want to make sure you're
wearing sunglasses utilizing
shade structures you're wearing a hat
you're paying attention to your skin
you can have a healthy tan absolutely
not so this is
complete fake news we know that uv light
is a known carcinogen so there really is
zero safe dose of uv light i would agree
healthy and tan do not go together by
definition when your skin is tanned it's
damaged and when you have damaged skin
you increase your risk of skin cancer we
know that approximately 90 percent of
all
skin cancers are directly related to
exposure to ultraviolet a and b
rays and guess what those are what
causes a skin to tan
exactly you know a tan is essentially
just your skin's stress response
so your skin is distressed when it stand
if you want
tan skin a understand that your skin is
okay
and beautiful the way it is but if you
for the summer want to look a little bit
tanner and you want to do that in a safe
way there are many companies that
provide
very safe sunless tanning creams lotions
and sprays
that can give you the look that you want
but also keep you safe and that is my
singular recommendation for being tan
getting a base tan will protect you from
a sunburn later on
the tanning salons will tell you that if
you get a base tan
before you go out into the sun it's
going to protect you so a base tan
probably gives you about you know an spf
of three so if you
burn in 20 minutes now you're going to
burn in 60 minutes that's nothing
it doesn't really help you significantly
but what it has done
is increase your risk for skin cancer
increase your risk for
accelerated aging and you know you know
a tan is temporary but your skin never
forgets
so what i tell my patients is that skin
cancer is like the straw that broke the
camel's back you never know when you're
getting that one last exposure that is
now going to tip your
skin cells over into being cancerous so
there really is zero safe level of uv
you can't get sunburned in the shade
incorrect so you can
absolutely get sunburned in the shade
now are you skiing are you at the beach
is there sand are you
sitting right next to an aluminum
garbage can no matter where you are
the sun can reflect off of the concrete
the sand the snow
especially with snow about 80 percent of
the sun's rays actually reflect
so you're actually still at risk and
still quite vulnerable even if you're
under a shade structure you only need
sunscreen if you're going
outside that is definitely a myth we
know for sure
that whether you're indoors sitting by a
window or if you're in a car driving
you are going to get exposure to
ultraviolet light
primarily it's ultraviolet a but as
we've been talking about ultraviolet a
is just as dangerous as ultraviolet b
and even then while these windows do
protect you against most of ultraviolet
b
it's not all of ultraviolet b curtains
aren't perfect because you know
clouds aren't even perfect right so uva
makes its way
completely through the clouds so
curtains alone won't do it you know
sunscreen alone won't do it it is a
comprehensive plan to keep your skin
safe i'm covered i applied sunscreen on
my face
arms and legs you're not covered
we also think about arms but what about
the backs of your hands and if you're
outside wearing flip-flops or open-toed
shoes sandals
the tops of your feet as well need to be
protected with sunscreen
the lips that's a an area that's really
high risk for skin cancer
and a skin cancer surgeon we know that's
one of the areas where skin cancers can
metastasize
another area the part when men lose
their protective covering on the scalp
you want to make sure that you're
protecting those areas
the chest behind the legs underneath the
chin
i treat skin cancers underneath the chin
all the time so even if you're just
out on a patio having lunch with a
friend that light is getting reflected
so don't forget underneath the chin as
well
getting sunburned once is harmless no
this is absolutely incorrect all it
takes is one
blistering sunburn in your lifetime to
increase your risk
of skin cancer one those young formative
years
not only are they psychologically
important but they're clinically
important
to keeping you safe we know that five
sunburns
before the age of 18 can double your
risk for melanoma so it's really
important
that you're protecting your skin early i
would say the best way to stay away from
us is actually coming to see us
oh yes they like it everyone as we said
everyone is incurring sun damage
everyone should have a skin check by a
board-certified dermatologist
and the idea is not just for the
dermatologist to take a look at your
skin but also have a conversation with
you about
what your skin looks like and how you
can prevent
future sun damage prevent development of
skin cancer what sunscreens might be
appropriate for you
once you've had one skin cancer you're
at an increased risk of having another
one in the next year
and so it's just once you've accumulated
that damage you continue to have them
and you continue to have them
and so it's really important that you
take every sun exposure seriously
because you never know when you're near
your tipping point and so yes
what has happened has happened but it
doesn't mean that it's too late and we
absolutely can do things for you to help
minimize the risk of development of skin
cancer in the future the sun
is strongest when it's hottest this is
not necessarily true
there's the heat that you feel over the
course today is actually cumulative so
for most of us we actually
feel the hottest a little later in the
day usually about three o'clock so
if you're out at 10 11 o'clock and you
don't feel it's all that hot outside
guess what that's when the uv is
actually strongest there are certain
times of the day
where the sun is at the highest in the
sky and at that period of time we
believe that the ultraviolet
light that we've talked about uva uvb is
at its strongest
and most damaging in general we talk
about 10 a.m
to 3 p.m it can vary slightly maybe 11
to 4
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
when it's hottest during the day the
little trick that i often use is the
shadow trick
if your shadow is shorter than you the
sun is higher in the sky
if your shadow is a little bit longer or
taller than you so in the late morning
or the late afternoon
then the sun is likely not at its peak
the other thing
to think about is on a cool day on a
cloudy day even on a winter day
high up in the mountains when you're
skiing you're getting ultraviolet
damage occurring people with darker skin
don't need sunscreen
so everyone needs sunscreen it does not
matter your skin type so we know that
melanin is protective
but melanin is not perfect so even the
deepest darkest skin
ranges from an spf let's say 4 to spf 13
and what do we recommend
spf 30 and above so even dark skin is
not 100
protective we know that we see skin
cancers in darker skin types
what's also important is that in darker
skin types there's often a lower index
of suspicion so
we find them later and because of this
the outcomes can be quite worse so
in darker skin types we see that the
five year survival for melanoma is about
65
and lighter skin types it's about 90 and
part of that is because of that
lower index of suspicion the thing about
skin of color is that
redness looks different sun damage looks
different but it's still
there skin cancers look different so
some of the most common skin cancers
like basal cell skin cancers
which we classically describe as a
pearly pink papule
and a darker skin patient might look
brown it might instead it's a pearly
brown papule
and so you know it's not that it doesn't
happen it's about being trained
in a way to read those changes because
they're there
they're present and it's critical to
find them all sunscreen works the same
fortunately they do not because variety
is really
important because different skin types
have different needs and so the two
broad categories of sunscreens are your
physical sunscreens and then your
chemical sunscreens
so chemical sunscreens work by bonding
with your skin
and they convert uv light to heat
physical sunscreens
lay on top of the skin and they reflect
uv light when we're talking about
physical sunscreens or physical blockers
those are the mineral sunscreens
in general we think of titanium dioxide
and zinc oxide as the two prominent
ingredients found in those sunscreens
if someone has really sensitive skin
they may not want to use a chemical
sunscreen not only because of the
chemicals
but because of that release of heat in
the news very recently there's a lot of
talk about
contaminants such as benzene as well as
the concern about whether or not yes are
we getting that spf protection are we
getting that sun protection that the
label is claiming that we do
we definitely need stronger regulation
by the fda we need more consistency and
standardization in the industry
but that being said applying your
sunscreen and using your sunscreen as
directed
is definitely better than not using it
at all absolutely
the best sunscreen for you is the
sunscreen that you will use it's a
wonderful thing that we have different
variations
creams for those who may have drier skin
and
enjoy that feeling of a richer cream
emotions for those who don't
gels for those who may have oily or
acne-prone skin
powders for those who want to reapply on
their makeup sprays for those who are
looking to catch their kids running away
on the beach
but don't inhale but don't inhale the
important point to make is there is no
waterproof sunscreen so while it's great
that if you
feel like you're either going swimming
or you're going to be sweating or very
active you want to use a water resistant
sunscreen i think it's
just as important that you realize once
you get out of that pool
or once you're ready to towel off after
a lot of sweating you reapply
you don't need sunscreen if your makeup
has spf no
and this is a common question i get in
the office frankly we don't apply our
foundation in the same way that we apply
our sunscreen
our sunscreen is a much more even
application if you're applying let's say
eye shadow with spf
most of us aren't applying a thick sheet
of eyeshadow over our eyelid
and so they're going to be areas of
vulnerability and as we've spoken about
before
it's not just about that spf number you
want to make sure that it's uva
protective too
and that's going to be found in your
sunscreen most likely not in your
moisturizer
for physical blockers i usually tell
people that will go on last
but the chemical sunscreens you maybe
want to put that on prior
to any other makeup that you'll be using
a big problem that happens is that we
become these mad scientists and these
chemists that we're not
and so when you start mixing
formulations and you don't understand
how to formulate
frankly what you're doing is you're
diluting your sunscreen and so if you're
mixing your spf with your moisturizer
now you have less protection
and we don't even know how these
formulations work together maybe it's
less than half
it's just far too risky you won't get
enough vitamin d
if you use sunscreen but there are more
than enough ways to get vitamin d that
don't cause skin cancer
so i recommend supplementation or you
know dairy products also have vitamin d
so there are many ways you can get
adequate vitamin d
that's not a carcinogen and if what
michelle said is not enough
sunscreen sunblock is not perfect so
you're still getting sun exposure
even when you apply sun protection
perfectly so
it's not as though you're completely
blocking the sun and you're not making
any vitamin d
you are making vitamin d you do not need
much sunlight to make vitamin d
so if i had to say three things to leave
you with
start young reapply it's not just about
that first application first thing in
the morning
and it's not just about sunscreen we've
talked about all the other things that
are involved in a comprehensive plan for
skin care and sun protection we're
excited about going outdoors our beaches
are going to be busy
we want to make sure that while we're
having fun we're still being responsible
so sunscreen to me is an evergreen topic
we should talk about it year round
but it's particularly important right
now